to give the awards and short films
dramatic action and animated are the two
glamorous or the glamorous and glorious
Lauren Hutton and Hollywood's most
generous and gifted tough guy Telly
Savalas
the nominees with the outstanding
achievement in short films animated our
dream dog Bob Godfrey and slotko British
producers every child Derek Lam producer
it's so nice to have a walk around the
house Paul feeling good
producing every child Derek Lam producer
thank you I wanted to bring director of
animation engine fader Inc Oh hoo hoo
here with me his fantastic animation has
made this possible and we really share
this award I like to say that every
child is a production of the National
Film Board of Canada in thanking the
Academy I'd like to say that this is the
third year in a row that you have
honoured us with the Oscar for animation
it's a great encouragement for the young
animators and for us to keep going
making hopefully good and innovative
films a big thank you to Rose knew of in
Toronto for her terrific work in this
film and to Lee means electrique in
montreal Bernard cares and Patricia bore
for a fantastic soundtrack and
characterizations every child is a funny
entertaining film but it has a serious
and important message this film has been
made - on behalf of UNICEF to promote
their efforts to help children who are
needy in all over the world the film
ends with a very direct message please
help UNICEF thank you thank you
the nominations for the outstanding
achievement in short films dramatic
action our board and care
Sarah Pillsbury and Ron Ellis producers
bravery in the field Roman Croydon
Stefan would allow ski producers
oh brother my brother
Carolyn Ross Lowell producers the solar
film Saul Bass and Michael Britten
producers Sally's Tyler Harry Matthias
Jesu cumin and Larry Anton producers and
the winner is the winner is board and
care south of
thank you all very much
and I would like to thank everybody who
puts so much time and energy into this
film particularly the people in
Porterville especially Ricky Goss I'd
also like to thank our director who
conceived of this project and Lila who
inspired thank you very much well I'm
not a talker I'm a filmmaker
but I would like to share this award and
I think the people who've seen this film
will understand why with my sister and
leading lady Laura Jean Ellis